last night storms brought strong winds
rain
frequent lightning and even flooding and
today rain and flooding reported in
western clark county
sally jaramillo has been all over the
valley this afternoon i understand she's
an anthem now where
some hail is coming
that's right denise we're in the anthem
area here in henderson where you can see
around at six o'clock hour
very busy very active we're hearing
lightning
we're seeing very heavy rain pouring
down i am
all over extremely wet right now you can
also start to notice we are
tracking those gusts possibly up to 30
to 40 miles per hour
and earlier we've been here all day long
tracking the reports that the storms
brought yesterday
this tree damage being the main impact
here
you can see it is still a primary
concern we are still
expecting chances of thunderstorm
activity for
tonight eventually clearing but then
chances return back again
later as we finish the week into the
weekend we want to make sure you stay
updated with 8 news now for all the
latest details right now
this is currently happening in anthem
we're getting reports of heavy rain i am
extremely soaked right now my shoes are
soaked
and rain just keeps going up and down
this
particular street this tree damage will
be clear up
as early as tomorrow that is what
that homeowner has just told us but
neighbors here in this area
were very concerned very scared of the
situation
sending it back to you guys now
oh no
it's a telephone pole she said that's a
telephone pole she is right plenty of
damage the past 24 hours here in the
valley
including downed trees ripped up
carports a lot of flooding
and again all of this happened in the
past 24 hours thank you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftus i'm denise
valdez with